this snake is about to do something
surprising I have been studying flying
snakes for over 20 years
and the reason that I find them so
interesting is that the snake is perhaps
the least obvious animal that should be
able to fly through the air it's thought
that these snakes
take to the air to avoid predators but
Jake's sohe has a lot of questions about
this unusual behavior one of the most
basic and important questions that we
have had is why does the snake
undulate in the air it's this very
striking motion that looks like it's
swimming in the air is it doing it
because it's a snake all snakes do this
or is there some underlying physical
function of this undulation Jake and his
team have been working with Chris Apulia
paradesi the paradise tree snake so this
is what a flying snake guy looks like it
flattens its body that produces more
lift and then it also undulates through
the air
Isak eaten helped set up an experiment
to measure flying snake undulation in
precise detail to determine what the
snake is doing in the air you have to
measure once along its body and in this
study to do that and we used a motion
capture system so this is the same
system you'd see in a Hollywood movie
they put markers on a person and then
track them in 3d space so we did that
exact same thing except we place markers
on the snake the team took over a
four-story black box theater they
covered the floor with foam and lifted
the snake high into the air
Chris prepared to see our tree snakes
and they're more comfortable in trees
and in branches and so we had a branch
for them to jump off of and in the
center of the theater we had also placed
a fake tree so this was to give them a
target to jump and glide to then it was
just a matter of persuading the snake to
show off for the cameras sometimes the
snakes really interested in getting away
from us and they would immediately jump
but sometimes it did need a little
prodding once the snake did take to the
air the pieces of tape on its back
provided data to the motion caption
cameras allowing Jake and Isaac to
create a 3d model of
the snakes movement one takeaway from
the studies that undulation increases
the stability of flying snake glides
when our model what we did is we see
mated glides within without undulation
and what we found is that without
undulation the cemented snake is still
going to cover some horizontal distance
but what happens is it fails and it
fails by basically tumbling over the
side-to-side undulation as well as a
previously undiscovered vertical
movement and now the snake to stay in an
upright position helping it glide safely
to the ground using undulation like this
is completely unique to flying snakes no
other gliding creature maintains
stability in this way and this new
mechanism for gliding could even be used
in robotics there's already been an
inspiration for borrowing snake
undulation and translating that into
robots and that's enabled those robots
to move on sand or to swim or even move
through really rough environments and so
we think that potentially you could use
what we found out about an aerial
undulation and translate that over into
the snake robot to have a successful
glory but for Jake sohe the satisfaction
is that another mystery of flying snakes
has been solved from the study we have a
new understanding of how flying snakes
glide what we now know is that the
undulation is not something that the
flying snakes are doing just because
there are a snake instead the undulation
is critical to their ability to glide so
with it their graceful glider without it
they're just another snake falling to
the ground
[Music]